three years we spent behind wolves it's
gonna break out now we're trying to
break back in well this movie this time
is uh it's the last of the kind of
trilogy of these major inner movies if
the first movies about them sort of
escaping the maze the second movie was
about them sort of surviving the Scorch
and the kind of endurance test that they
had it placed upon them this one is
really where this the journey kind of
ends it's a rescue mission movie it's to
go after mean home basically and Thomas
and the gang have to kind of as a small
unit sort of go up against essentially
Goliath there's no guarantee we make it
back from this totally stop this
together as well I need it that way too
I was a very conscious decision actually
to not paint our villains essentially of
the movie is just cliche bad guys that
are just all evil this third movies
about confronting in the world is
usually not black and white you can
think your friends you can see his home
the beating heart of these movies where
the characters you know so I've always
tried to keep track of that that most of
the fans it's not the concepts that that
drive in these movies is to gets the
characters and the kind of relationship
between them in the drama between how
many cases do they have to round up when
the hell does it stop
it stops when we find a cure we're a
smaller book series but hopefully the
fans feel like we've died justice as a
big movie
basically the idea behind IMAX we kind
of set out very early on with this
concept I always thought it would be
interesting to kind of show the IMAX
fans but the larger screen format the
bigger sound the kind of bigger picture
in general to give them something more
basically and we've always been a tattoo
4'o aspect ratio for our movies and that
means basically something like this in
turn in terms of that your screen size
with IMAX we actually shoot this much we
shot early on specifically for this we
did all the effects specifically for
this so it's nice to go to a place that
takes that into account appreciates that
effort that we all put in all the
craftsmen that go and work on these
movies
it's kind of you obviously way bigger
it's gonna be more immersive it's gonna
louder more emotional everything so I
think fans will love it in this format
[Music]